bonjour jean philippe tanguy merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
rt france est le port du masque est
obligatoire malheureusement cela a un
coût et tout le monde ne peut pas s'en
procurer on vient de l'entendre gabriel
attal a annoncé aujourd'hui que des
masques serait à distribuer aux plus
précaires à ce que cette mesure est
suffisante et est ce qu'elle vous
satisfait écoutez c'est une première
mesure qui est de bon sens car vous
savez il ya beaucoup de personnes en
france
ils sont fragiles en difficulté de santé
en difficulté de revenus je pense aussi
aux petites retraites aux personnes en
situation de handicap qui sont très
angoissés à l'idée d'avoir un budget
important de masse avec des revenus
limitée qui ne leur permettent pas de
sortir dans de bonnes conditions et
d'avoir une vie à la fois normal et
sécurisé mais là où le gouvernement est
extrême mauvaise foi c'est qu'il oublie
de dire que dans l'ensemble des rapports
sanitaire qui étaient censées protéger
la france en cas d'épidémie et notamment
un rapport de mai et 19 de l'agent santé
france il était prévu que le stock
stratégique à savoir un milliard de
masques soit distribué sous la forme de
lots de 50 masques par foyer tous les
mois aux français est en fait c'est
l'absence de stocks qui oblige
aujourd'hui les français à devoir payer
eux mêmes leurs masques et pourquoi
c'est une mesure de bon sens parce que
il faut savoir que par exemple à taïwan
qui n'est pas un pays communiste
on distribue chaque semaine en pharmacie
via la carte vitale à l'équivalent la
carte vitale à taïwan un lot à chaque
famille pourquoi parce que si la
population n'est pas bien protégé
si des personnes avec de faibles revenus
font le choix de ne pas avoir de masques
ou d'avoir de mauvais match c'est tout
le pays qui est menacée donc en faisant
une toute petite économie de bout de
chandelle on menace toute l'économie de
s'effondrer à nouveau et on sait ce que
ça a coûté à la france
cinq cent mille masques seront mises à
disposition des lycéens d'île de france
également à la rentrée annonce faite par
la présidente de la région
est ce qu'il y aura des déséquilibres
des inégalités entre chaque région en
france également à propos de ces masques
en fait il y en a déjà car vous savez
qu'il ya beaucoup de municipalités qui
ont distribué des masques notamment des
masques en tissu
à leurs habitants et d'autres qui ne
l'ont pas fait parce qu'en france il ya
des communes riches il y a des communes
pauvres
il ya des bons mer il ya des mois bon
élu donc il ya déjà des inégalités c'est
pour ça qu'il y avait ce stock national
j'ajoute que on sait depuis maintenant
un mois que nous avons plus de 40
millions de masques en tissu invendus
fabriqué en france qui nous restent sur
le dos parce que le gouvernement
toujours aussi incompétent a commandé
des masques
ici au vietnam ici à la chine au lieu de
faire passer en priorité la commande
nationale donc de toutes façons ces
masses il existe 20 à 40 millions donc
autant les reprendre plus tôt que les
gens voyaient à la poubelle pour donner
du travail en france est aux français
pardon et ont plus distribuer des
masques de façon juste de toute façon il
existe
j'ajoute aussi les luttes monsieur attal
veut envoyer des masques par envoi
postal au personnage c'est complètement
stupide
ça coûte beaucoup plus cher d'envoyer un
colis que de faire un masque pour tout
le monde qu'on retire à la pharmacie
c'est une question d'économie d'échelle
donc en fait ce gouvernement on comprend
rien il veut pas faire l'économie en
fait ses pieds il veut envoyer un signal
politique toujours le même pour le fait
qu'il ait pas de politique juste en
france et qu'il n'a en fait pas les
masques aux nécessaires pour tout le
monde car on en revient toujours au même
problème
le stocks stratégiques de 1 milliard de
masques n'existe toujours pas c'est ça
la vérité qui viennent à dire
l'incapacité du gouvernement a distribué
des masques y compris pardon je reviens
au fait que d'autres gouvernements
notamment en asie sont capables de le
faire parce que eux a baissé ses stocks
stratégiques
donc une fois de plus le gouvernement
fait passer pour des décisions le fait
d'être incompétent il ya des
cafouillages au niveau des basques mais
aussi nous détestent mais passer de 330
milles à 3 177 mille tests par semaine
et les laboratoires sont débordés alors
que la france serait prête à faire 700
mille dépistages elle de madère comment
vous expliquez ce cafouillage nicolas
dupont aignan critique
emmanuel macron et et le gouvernement à
ce sujet vous aussi j'imagine ah mais
c'est toujours le même problème c'est
que le gouvernement ne s'est pas
organiser une réponse sanitaire
ristic à la crise comme par hasard c'est
l'île de france qui ne fait plus est
débordé le gouvernement n'a toujours pas
compris que l'île de france de par la
densité de population de par le fait que
c'est une zone à la fois touristique et
une zone d'affaires où il ya beaucoup de
circulation beaucoup de brassage la
population doit avoir des capacités de
test supérieur à des territoires qui
sont plus isolés et de fait tant mieux
pour eux plus protégés donc c'est
toujours le même problème ce
gouvernement est incapable d'organiser
les choses et en plus ne tire pas les
leçons de notre pays qui réussissent
mieux comme l'allemagne à nos portes
c'est toujours un problème de
désorganisation et en plus il raconte
n'importe quoi c'est que nassim ils
mentent en fait aux français quand il
faut dire la vérité ils mentent aux
français car ils sont incapables de
produire des résultats et une fois que
c'est possible d'autres pays arabes
ça sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
jean philippe tanguy d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt frange rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole de debout la
france